the mother of dragons has opened up
about some of her biggest
behind-the-scenes battles in the months
after the extraordinarily divisive
ending of Game of Thrones which closed
out its epic eight season run in May
2019 Emilia Clarke who played the
nearest Targaryen on the series has
spoken out about tough moments she
experienced during filming namely the
scenes in which she appeared in the buff
and there were quite a few speaking with
actor Doug Shepard on his podcast
armchair experts Clark got candid about
the pressure to perform while bearing at
all and the toll it took on her
especially considering the fact that she
was quite young when she began her
tenure on Thrones [ __ ] told Shepard that
she suffered from serious impostor
syndrome while filming saying I've been
on a film set twice before then and now
I'm on a film set completely naked with
all of these people and I don't know
what I meant to do and I don't know
what's expected of me and I don't know
what you want and I don't know what I
want she told Shepard that both her
clothed and enclosed scenes on Game of
Thrones caused her feelings of anxiety
and self-doubt
luckily Clark had an ally in Aquaman
himself Jason Momoa who played her
husband called Drogo during the show's
first season Momoa completely had her
back during these difficult sequences he
was an experienced actor who had done a
bunch of stuff before coming onto this
he was like sweetie this is how it's
meant to be and this is how it's not
meant to be and I'm gonna make sure that
that's guys clearly Momoa was warmly
protective of Clark who appreciated it
immensely he was so kind as a prince and
such yeah and consider it and like cared
about me as a human being however as
more time went by Clark realized she had
the clout to stick up for herself on set
saying that she became a lot more savvy
about what she's comfortable doing I've
had fights on set before where I'm like
no she's up there like you don't want to
disappoint you Game of Thrones fans and
I'm like by the time she had to perform
a final nude scene which took place on
the season 6 episode book of The
Stranger Clark took control saying I'm
owning this this is mine
they've asked me to do it and I'm in
game Game of Thrones featured plenty of
full frontal scenes during us decade
long run and Clark performed her fair
share from her wedding night with Khal
Drogo to her rebirth from the flames
that gave way to our dragons some of
those sequences actually made sense
the plot of the show beyond that there
were a handful of scenes during which
Clarkston era simply stripped down for
no narrative reason which obviously took
its toll on the actress Thrones became
infamous throughout its run for using
sex and nudity as narrative devices even
when it barely made sense to do so and
clearly the comments made to Clarke
about keeping her fans happy was no
outlier director Neil Marshall who
helmed the season 2 episode Blackwater
once opened up about how studio
executives wished him to add titillation
when it wasn't needed
proving that HBO press were likely more
concerned with ratings than how the Game
of Thrones casting crew felt about the
unset environment in the end it's great
that Clarke found the strength to stand
up for herself and that stars like Momoa
stuck up for her when she couldn't but
it's unsettling that the higher-ups
behind Game of Thrones pushed such a
young actress in the performing scenes
that made her uncomfortable ultimately
Clarke is clearly still proud of the
show that brought her international fame
and how she handled this important onset
dilemma will almost definitely help
young stars going forward if you miss
Khaleesi Game of Thrones are streaming
in its entirety on HBO go and HBO on
demand if you want to catch Clarke in a
new role her latest film last Christmas
is in theaters now check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite actors
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bowel so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]